speaking of totally derailing I saw this
one this morning this is from Bloomberg
Vice media has filed for bankruptcy
protection punctuating a relatively
rapid decline for the media upstart that
once boasted a
5.7 billion dollar valuation this is
really big guys for those of you
watching this you probably don't pay
that much attention to Vice but Vice
about you know maybe eight years ago a
decade ago like they were the first sort
of alt media right so we had we had
Network News NBC ABC CBS then we had
cable news CNN MSNBC Fox News then there
was like the alt online media company so
there was vice there was BuzzFeed Etc
now BuzzFeed as you know folded a couple
weeks ago now Vice is worth it's worth
nothing it's worth absolutely nothing
after being valued at 5.7 billion
because they went woke too so it proves
the theory go woke go broke that's how
it worked next
[Music]
foreign